welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who can do
this all day and in this video we're
going to be breaking down some of the
best easter eggs and hidden details i
noticed in the first avenger the movie
sets up so many things in the mcu that
don't pay off until much later and it's
a film that's got better with age due to
what we now know if you haven't had a
chance to check out the latest mcu films
and shows then take all the stupid with
you as there will be heavy spoilers here
smash the thumbs up button if you enjoy
the breakdown and don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this each and
every day without the way thanks for
clicking this now let's get into captain
america the first adventure okay so the
movie opens with an excavation in the
ice that unearths captain america this
pulls heavily from the source material
and originally cap was a character used
by timely and atlas comics who were
predecessors of marvel cap was brought
back in the 60s after he was thawed from
ice and over the years they've used this
reboot device to kind of keep him a
similar sort of age originally he was
meant to be unearthed in the incredible
hulk during a deleted scene in which the
titular character hulk smashed some ice
however they changed it up so we were
introduced to him at the beginning of
his own movie from here we jump to
tonesburg which is a very important
location in the mcu if we look at the
timeline it chronologically appeared
first at the beginning of thor when odin
fought the frost giants its next
appearance was here and it showed up in
ragnarok as the place odin went to
before he died odin said to both of his
sons remember this place home and after
it was destroyed the survivors ended up
settling there an endgame red skull then
arrives in his car which has a design
that's based heavily on a v16 roadster
the roadster pulls in with a focus on
the hydra logo and this would later be
used in animated form during what if we
learn that red skull is here for the
tesseract which has appeared in a number
of things at the end of the film we see
that howard stark discovers it in the
ocean and learning an endgame that at
project pegasus they had a whole science
division headed up by him centered
around it this was teased at during iron
man 2 when tony was going through his
dad's things and in one of his notebooks
we saw a sketch of the cube the
tesseract is actually heavily based on
the cosmic cube which has also appeared
in a number of comics and primarily that
was the thing that red skull saw after
the most back in 2011 this led us to
believe that this was the cosmic cube
but as we learned throughout the soccer
it's simply a housing for the space
stone now whilst this probably wasn't
intentional red skull smashes a fake
version of the cube which sort of comes
back around when thanos smashes it in
his hands to reveal the stone i know it
definitely wouldn't have been meant at
the time but they don't call me reach
richards for nothing now shout out to
the canadian lad for pointing out that
when red skull first enters the church
we can see three soldiers trying to push
the tomb open where the fake tesseract
is held they all fail but skull is able
to do it single-handedly showing what
kind of strength that he has red skull
discovers the tesseract hidden inside a
giant mural of the world tree that pulls
from nose mythology at the end of thor
when loki freezes the bifrost sword in
place he actually creates a gigantic ice
structure that looks exactly like this
we also know from the trailer of what if
that it will be appearing at some point
in the series so this is a nice little
detail to have in this movie the idea of
the aryan superman actually pulls from
norse mythology 2 and it was said that
hitler believed that people born with
blonde hair and blue eyes were descended
from the gods this kinda explains why
thor had those features in his first
movie but i don't care what you say yeah
nothing can excuse those blonde eyebrows
nothing now during this scene we also
get a lot of foreshadowing about the
eventual reveal of red skull including a
line which can be seen below johann
schmitz yeah this is where the mask
seems join up with one another and his
hydro pin also gets blood splattered on
the skull which foreshadows that he's
red skull yes it's a reach now shout
outs tim gettys that kind of funny for
pointing out that this movie was
directed by joe johnson who also worked
on raiders of the lost ark that follows
indiana jones as he tries to get the ark
of the covenant and there is of course a
scene in which the nazis dig in the
desert red skull actually says a line
about how hitler is currently digging
for trinkets in the desert and this
could be joe referring to his own work
in which that happened interestingly
raiders actually ended with the villains
dying whilst a gigantic fire was shot
into the sky which is sort of similar to
how red skull is taken out steve then
attempts to enlist in the 107th division
which we learn his father was a part of
this is actually the one that bucky ends
up in and during what if whilst he's
recovering from being shot steve
mentions him as being part of this
regiment as he stands up we can see a
man reading a newspaper behind him and
the headline for this says elite nazi
forces over a norwegian town this
further calls back to the intro and it's
a nice little detail that kind of ties
those two scenes together after shouting
down a bully steve ends up having to
fight in an alleyway and he grabs a
trash can lid which foreshadows the
character using a shield he says the
infamous words i can do this all day
which have popped up numerous times in
the mcu whenever the character has
almost been beaten yeah i know he said
it an end game just for the sake of it
but hey it was a good line now
interestingly bucky arrives and breaks
up the fight and in falcon in the winter
soldier episode 1 we see him breaking up
another fight in an alley over a bin as
well he helps steve out and steve asks
where they're going to which bucky
replies the future this of course sets
up how both would end up traveling
decades ahead and reuniting in the
winter soldier we can also catch his
enlistment form which lists his birthday
as the 4th of july aka independence day
next we see the stark expo which is
based on the world's fair at one of the
stands we see a mannequin in a red suit
inside of a glass chamber the name above
it says phineas horton and both of these
are notes to the original human torch
and the scientists that created him
chris evans of course played the human
torch in the fantastic four movies so
it's sort of like poetry they rhyme now
this stark expo later appears in iron
man 2 and the layout of it is how tony
figures out how to create a new element
that will power his suit without
poisoning him howard demonstrates his
flying car and this actually sets up his
son's costume in some way the hovering
capabilities are very similar to what
would be adapted into the iron man suit
and tony actually picked the colours of
iron man after looking at his own hot
rod the idea of a flying red car would
also be pulled across the agents of
shield namely as being agent coulson's
car lola steve walks up to a glass
display of soldiers but his eyes don't
line up with the face throughout his
trilogy both he and bucky visit similar
exhibits and in falcon in the winter
soldier episode 1 sam stood in front of
the shield but he was slightly
off-center from it this showcased that
he wasn't quite there yet much like how
steve isn't and this iconography is also
used in into the spider-verse miles
didn't fully line up with peter's mask
in the cave at one point but by the end
of the movie he did steve goes to
attempt to enlist once more and bucky
leaves to go and serve he says don't do
anything stupid until i get back to
which steve replies how can i you're
taking all this stupid with you this
wouldn't pay off until endgame when it
was the parting words between the pair
before steve traveled back in time to
live with peggy after being caught for
falsifying his enlistment form dr
erskine intervenes in order to make it
so that he can be part of the super
soldier serum program erskine says he's
from queens when steve first asks but
then he goes into how before that he was
from germany steve tells him he's from
brooklyn and this sort of mirrors the
exchange between steve and peter parker
and civil war in which the pair both say
where they're from erskine puts steve
through his paces in a camp and he
proves to everyone else that steve is
worthy by showing that he will jump on a
grenade in order to save others
interestingly in the scene we can also
see that peggy was willing to jump on it
too but steve got there first however it
does help us to understand why she was
worthy enough to get the super soldier
serum in what if and it's a nice little
character moment that sort of sets up
what's to come in falcon in the winter
soldier we do learn that john walker had
been through similar situations with
grenades but that he'd used his helmet
to cover the blast showing that he
wasn't really cut out like steve was but
that he still viewed himself as being
there erskine says that the serum
enhances what character traits the man
has and therefore we can see why walker
ended up the way that he did we learned
in the mcu that banner and general ross
were trying to replicate the formula
created by erskine and this led to the
hulk as well as the abomination banner
deals with a lot of internal anger
throughout most of his depictions and
emil blonsky is of course power hungry
therefore erskine saying this sets up
how different characters who take the
serum all end up with slightly different
results now following world war ii the
camp itself was turned into shield
headquarters and both steven natasha
traveled to it in the winter soldier it
also appeared in endgame as the
aforementioned place that the tesseract
studies happened and it was a location
that hank pym worked out of now when we
meet arnhem zola we see his face through
a magnifying glass which massively
distorts it and this foreshadows how he
would end up becoming a face on a screen
during the winter soldier zola's face
could also be caught in the background
of end game as tony snuck around looking
for the tesseract in the comics zola had
a gigantic body that looked a lot like a
teletubby and when he packs things up in
the film we can catch schematics for
this also yeah never forget that
ryanairy bloody ryanairy said that zola
would be the main body for falcon in the
winter soldier do not ever let that lad
live it down i know i got my fist all
wrong here but
that was valid that and i'm not i'm not
having anyone say anything else you're
bastard now peggy and steve go to the
lab and the pair talk about dancing and
how the latter hasn't found the right
partner yet this idea of the pair
dancing appears throughout the mcu and
as steve is making his sacrifice play at
the end of the movie he of course
organizes a date between them
interestingly he says he'd hate to step
on peggy's toes and in the car he talks
about how he might do this in age of
ultron when steve is put under an
illusion by scholar witch he imagines
meeting her for that dance and the saga
of course ends with him traveling back
in time to do it
in what if we learn that this scene is
pivotal to the creation of a branched
reality whereas in the original film the
observers go up to the observation room
in the animated show they stay in the
lab this allows the hydra agent to blow
his cigarette case destroying most of
the scientists and machines whereas in
the former film he was out the way he
also did it after the experiment whereas
in what if he does it before now i
absolutely love how much attention to
detail that what if has and several of
the shots from the scene are recreated
perfectly in the first episode they
managed to capture so many things such
as howard lowering his glasses which
happens exactly the same way just as
steve and peggy are injected their eyes
also shoot open and the way that the
machine opens up is pretty much
identical across the board interestingly
this idea of eyes shooting open when the
serum hits could be a nod of the hulk in
his super soldier experiment as when
edward norton's version transforms his
eyes to open up now this shot and the
framing device of it is mirrored in the
winter soldier when bucky is getting his
memory wiped in that we catch a
shirtless bucky strapped in with clamps
around him and we follow from this to a
focus on his face much like how we get
with steve in the lab the hydra agent
shoots erskine and this changes for what
if when he instead shoots tommy lee
jones's chest to phillips weirdly
erskine's death sort of repeats a one
from earlier in the franchise namely dr
yinsen's both were kindly scientist
characters that helped to form the
hero's origins and even their death
scenes are shot the same way the pair
both lie on their backs as the hero
leans over them and listens to their
last words i don't know if marvel did
this on purpose or if they're just lucky
but when yinzin dies he lies in a sack
which has an american flag inside of a
circle and it could be foreshadowing the
similar scene that captain america would
go through with his mentor or it could
be a big reach
now peggy chases after the hydra agent
and she shoots the driver of his escape
vehicle a similar shot to this would
also be used in what if when she kills
the agent in the lab the idea of hydra
agents being part of the government
would of course reoccur in the winter
soldier and it's sort of like poetry
because it it shows up again and is a
bit similar now steve chases after him
and uses a cab door as a shield which
just so happens to have a star on it in
the crowd we can also see a woman taking
a photograph of this moment and this
picture would actually appear in the
captain america display that we see in
falcon and the winter soldier nazi
soldiers show up to investigate schmidt
and he ends up using the tesseract
weapons on them in what if because zola
is a prisoner at this point he can't
create these weapons and their skull
ends up shooting a soldier with a
standard german pistol which is called a
mauser now these weapons would later
show up in the avengers when steve is
looking through the helicarrier and it
shows that shield are just as shady as
hydra are which spoiler alert that's
because they're one in the same now
having the tesseract massively helps
howard to build the hydra stomper which
is of course the what-if version of iron
man's armor it was actually theorized by
eric boss at new rock stars that the
tesseract might have been what helped to
create the giant arc reactor that we saw
in iron man 1 and i really love this
theory as we know how it of course
worked on it we do get a scene in which
howard actually cuts a piece out of the
tesseract and it ends up exploding a
similar scene to this happens in endgame
when tony is inspecting the infinity
stones and rocket says boom to give him
a shock this was of course a nod to how
it exploded with howard and it's a
really cool easter egg that calls back
to this movie steve ends up going on a
propaganda tour and in what if he
jokingly said that peggy might end up on
this chester philip says to steve that
he wanted a soldier and that all he got
was a chorus girl and this is reflected
in what if when flynn says he wanted a
soldier but all he got was a girl flynn
actually appeared earlier in the mcu
namely the one shot agent carter in
which he too looked down on peggy
because she was a woman also shout out
to everyone who pointed that out on my
wife breakdown i was absolutely kicking
myself but as always you guys are the
real heroes now steve and his group of
chorus girls perform the star spangled
man with a plan throughout the country
and this is pretty good satire on how
the real life cap was used as a tool for
propaganda he also punches hitler
several times which is a nod to captain
america issue one now shout out to ryan
airy from screen crush for pointing out
that the mcu version of the comic has
bucky missing from the cover the
original one had him on but as he was in
his sidekick at this point in the story
they actually removed him now i know i'm
doing a lot of shout outs in this video
as well but come on yeah these lads
deserve the views too now we pull out to
see the entire stage which is actually
set up to look a lot like cap shield due
to its white and red circular lines and
also the star in the middle that cap
stands in front of during this we see a
woman run up to steve and this is laura
haddock who would go on to play peter
quill's mum meredith this might actually
be quill's grandma and sometimes you
just gotta wreck on this stuff in your
head so that it's really good at the
song star spangled man of course showed
up reworked in falcon in the winter
soldier during the john walker parade
and cap peggy and john and his wife
olivia do share similar moments this is
seen in both properties in which the
caps sit down on the bench doubting
themselves whilst their love interests
stand above them and it shows how much
marvel pay attention to the small things
steve ends up drawing himself as a
performing monkey and this sketch
actually appears in his room during
civil war after learning of the soldiers
trapped behind enemy lines steve heads
out to rescue them and something similar
would be carried out by isaiah bradley
however whereas steve came home to a
hero's welcome isaiah was locked up and
experimented on because the us didn't
want a black man to be captain america
at the facility we meet the howling
commandos namely dum dum duggan who
comes from the comics there's also union
jack as well as jim morita marina is
played by kenneth choi who would like to
show up in homecoming as the principal
in his office we can see a picture of
maria showing that the two were related
and see yeah that meredith theory it
wasn't that bad now it's during this
time that stanley cameos and alongside
him is rev brown who played captain
america in the 70s steve saves bucky
who's being experimented on and this
would set up how he survives the fall
and becomes the winter soldier
interestingly in what if this doesn't
happen as zola has of course been
captured at this point throughout the
film there's also a bar scene in which
bucky and steve sit and talk him what if
as peggy hasn't rescued him at this
point they instead have howard appearing
red skull escapes in a rocket like plane
and this could also be seen in the void
during loki episode 5. after using a
prop shield for the mission stark then
gives him a vibranium one the first time
we see this it's silver and later on it
gets its full colouring this is sort of
similar to what happened to tony's iron
man suit and originally he had a silver
one before adding the yellow and red to
it we then get some footage of steve on
missions and he looks at his compass
which has a picture of peggy in it this
iconography shows up throughout the mcu
and he looks at it in several films at
the end of the first avenger he pops it
open before crashing into the ice and he
also looks at it in the winter soldier
when visiting the captain america
exhibit cap also looked at it in
infinity war and before traveling into
space in endgame he stared at it too it
clearly holds a lot of meaning to him
and is the thing he looks to to remind
him of the good in the world that he's
fighting for a howling commandos then
attempt the train mission which we learn
in what if is called where eagles stare
this is actually a nod to a film set
during the second world war which
involves infiltrating a castle similar
to what happens in the disney plus show
in the series red skull's mission
changes up and he wants to summon
schumer gorath thus a castle makes a lot
of sense to do this at in the film
though he plans to drop bombs and thus
he needs somewhere with a runway on the
ships carrying the explosives all
locations and these are written on
similar to how steve writes hello from
brooklyn on the hydra stomper in the
series peggy pulls bucky up and he says
that she almost took his arm off which
is of course a nod to how he'd lose it
as the winter soldier we learned capcom
get drunk and peggy also says this in
the show when meeting steve in a bar she
also steals a motorbike and writes it
similar to how steve does when he leads
the charge on the hydra base here steve
ends up coming face to face with the red
skull and he says that he's seen the
future and that there are no flags this
is a mentality that the flag smashers
would embody as they wanted to live in a
world without borders red skull is sent
across space to guard the soul stone on
boromir and cat becomes a capsicule for
70 yes we see peggy taking the photo of
steve out of a folder and she would of
course have this on her desk in endgame
this mirrors how he took a picture of
her and i'm so glad that they got that
dance together i'm not crying you you're
crying
as steve is awoken in new york and he
runs out into times square in a scene
that mirrors him running through new
york earlier in the movie the
post-credits scene too works as a
trailer for the avengers but it also has
a scene from that movie in which cap
goes ham on a punching bag peggy 2 does
this and what if and punches it off its
chain at one point much like how cap
does she ends up becoming the woman out
of time and it's going to be interesting
to see how the season ends up sending
her back anyway that's all of the easter
eggs similarities and hidden details
that we could find obviously if i missed
any then let me know below and as a
thank you you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of august in
which we're giving away three mc boxes
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the video if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of what if episode 1 which
will be linked on screen right now
there's a lot of easter eggs in it and
also many of them differ from this so
definitely go check it out right after
this if not then thank you for singing
to the video i've been paul i'll see you
next time take care peace
i